so much recognition for the movie such a
huge box-office Jamie Lee Curtis was
just saying you guys didn't necessarily
see all this coming for this one you you
make a movie you hope for the best
I mean everybody was gonna walk down
this line is going to tell you that and
it doesn't always work out and this is
one of those situations where the
audience does seem to get it and you
know I couldn't be prouder of a movie
and couldn't be proud of my part in it
well the accent really worked out people
are obsessed what was the inspiration
for the accent there are a number that
any see Williams was the first
inspiration but then as a historian
called Shelby Foote who I just listened
to day after day and just he went in it
so oh and a sequel right I mean Jamie
Lee just basically told me you're doing
a sequel it's being built around your
character I don't Jamie Lee says history
it must be true would you come back for
it though sure yeah yeah I also got to
ask you how excited are you and to
support Rachel and Black Widow we can't
wait to see that she doesn't need my
support but yes it's going to be great I
can't wait I mean that I'm sure it's
going to be a really great movie
Scarlett and Florence and that's a
really great cause so much awards
recognition for the movie and a huge box
office good combo platter very
unexpected it wasn't for you guys oh
yeah I mean I think we all knew the
movie would be good we saw it in Toronto
we know it was good we actually knew it
was great but you just don't know if an
audience is going to support it you just
don't know if it's gonna have that kind
of exposure so much support that now
we're hearing sequel rumors could you
make a camp no no no I don't know no
there will be a sequel they will for
sure
fo sho as the kids say will we get you
in it in anyway no oh no no yeah I
believe it will be another benoît long
mystery and it'll be a whole new group
of people and the throm bees will be off
you
doing what they do well I mean we love
you and anything that we can get you in
but you're gonna be back and well you're
gonna be back in the Halloween can you
tease anything for us I'm in it that all
we get it's special I've got this it'll
be a trilogy and it'll be a trilogy I
think people will really remember as
something very powerful will that be the
ending of Halloween for you we missed
you at the globe is where you at home
Washington your pajamas we've got a
little heart in my jammies I mean I like
I like to go if I have a job I did not
have a job so therefore I I posted a
picture of me watching the Globes in my
pajamas with my dog Rooney wearing Chris
Evans sweater
they made a dog sweater out of Chris
Evans sweater so my dog Rooney that's as
meta as I think the world gets Chris
Evans was on the screen there's my dog
in Chris Evans sweater from the movie I
thought that was I think I kind of won
or a one-on-one Instagram
[Music]